today we're gonna be talking about
health and fitness as any guy with man
Stein will tell you the right diet and
plenty of exercise is just as important
as having the latest cellphone or
knowing who fights this the key to
staying in shape is knowing how to
defend yourself what I feel great let's
do this the centerpiece of any fitness
habit is cardio which is short for
cardio workout it's all about getting
your heart rate up to measure pulse use
your fingers to look for big thick an
attack and come at any time the first
rule of cardio is never let your guard
down cardio is all around us you can do
it anywhere use the stairs at work or
take lots of tiny fast steps even a walk
to the bathroom can be a real workout
the second rule of cardio is never let
your guard down if you want to protect
yourself we've got to get strong
but you don't have to join a gym to
build muscle you can just use everyday
objects you find around the house like
this set of weights there's no one way
to weight train but everyone agrees that
it's really important to find some heavy
stuff and then pick it up a lot use your
weights to simulate an attacker here and
snap the attackers hands off the wrists
when using his own hands to beat him in
the face
I like strengthening my core with
resistance train train your core to
resist this playground the key to
physical fitness is to always have a
safe word just like a truck or a Jeep
your body needs fuel
any time you're exercising or fighting a
great snack is obscurity just take half
a banana six scoops of protein powder
coffee and heavy cream now if it's too
thick just add an egg
it's also a great way to lose those
Thanksgiving turkey pounds just a
smoothie for breakfast a smoothie after
breakfast a smoothie before lunch a
smoothie for lunch a smoothie after
lunch is smoothie before dinner a
sensible dinner and a smoothie for
dessert say goodbye to those cravings
once you've got a routine that works for
you it's important to stay motivated
mind and body if you see other people
that are healthy they'll make you feel
better
so keep healthy imagery around just
looking at all these healthy guys makes
me feel great oh he's yelling is it how
healthy is look at this one very healthy
he looks like he's late for the health
food store dr. drew knows all about
health you can't tell with the clothes
but I think under his clothes he's
really healthy like dude the clothes you
can still see he's healthy owner there
yeah it's like whoa who's almost too
healthy I like this one a lot of help I
do think that these two guys are friends
I've seen pictures of this self owner
shirt and it's very healthy I like this
guy that I came off once you know what
to look for you'll find inspiration
everywhere now that you're healthy it's
time to take the next step and buy a
knife you never know what's out there
you don't need to buy a knife but good
health does help improve all aspects of
your life from buying tight pants to
very tight shirts buy a knife car do you
need to relax you need to go to the
hospital what playground playground wait